me llamo steiner y este es mi segundo
año enseñando en la escuela pública de
la escuela omni una escuela con fondos
públicos que a partir de este año es
administrada por aspira en un esfuerzo
por mejorar sus condiciones la escuela
al noreste de filadelfia ha estado en la
lista de las de más bajo nivel por
varios años y tiene algunos de los
resultados académicos más bajos de la
ciudad
este año tengo el privilegio de enseñar
matemáticas en el último grado para
cuando llegan al último año hay un
amplio rango de habilidades algunos de
ellos van a ir a la universidad y tienen
un nivel alto de matemáticas otros están
batallando con tablas de multiplicar
y tener a tantos alumnos diferentes con
diversos niveles de conocimiento
provocaba muchos problemas en el salón
para atender las necesidades de todos
los alumnos hay veces que siento que
estoy corriendo en un maratón al tratar
de llegar de un alumno a otro me
encantaría poder darles a los alumnos la
atención personal que necesitan no me
gusta que los demás entiendan el tema
antes que yo
si no entiendo lo que pasa en clase me
pongo a distraer a los otros si no hago
mi trabajo
solo distraigo a los demás si el tema es
muy difícil y el profesor no viene a
ayudarme agachó la cabeza y me duermo me
rindo
me molesta cuando yo quiero aprender
algo nuevo y no podemos tenemos que
repasar cosas una y otra vez lo que
comenzó a frustrarme muy pronto era que
fuera de la escuela los alumnos viven en
un mundo acelerado en el que siempre
están en el celular o en internet o
jugando mientras que en el salón quieren
que dé clases con un modelo del siglo 19
con el profesor dando cátedra al frente
y un objetivo en el pizarrón para todos
los alumnos
estuve mucho tiempo pensando en cómo
introducir la tecnología en mi salón y
cómo asegurarme de que tanto los alumnos
avanzados como los atrasados aprendieran
me propuse conseguir computadoras para
mi salón sabía que si las usaba bien
podía beneficiar a mis alumnos y
ayudarme mucho amigo encontré una
organización que me vendió 10
computadoras usadas a 100 dólares cada
una y con la ayuda de algunos amigos y
familiares puede recaudar el dinero para
pagarlas
desde el principio tanto a mis alumnos
como a mí nos encantó el programa gratis
en línea khan academy ellos podían
trabajar individualmente en temas de su
propio nivel practicando con ejercicios
interactivos viendo vídeos y me permití
a mí monitorear fácilmente su avance
una vez que encontré varias maneras de
implementar khan academy el cambio en mi
salón fue extraordinario
khan academy ha hecho que la clase esté
enfocada en los alumnos la oportunidad
de diferenciar ha hecho que los alumnos
tengan mayor confianza en sí mismos y
mayor entusiasmo por aprender
me gusta tener varios temas de donde
elegir porque puedo ver lo que logrado
el maestro viene y tiene como 30 alumnos
más en la clase así que no puede
ayudarme enseguida pero la computadora
me da la información inmediata si estás
con un problema y lo tienes mal te lo
dice de inmediato y luego te lo explica
ahora uso las computadoras todos los
días puedo agrupar a los alumnos por
nivel de habilidad o por estilo de
aprendizaje khan academy no solo ayuda
para fortalecer los conocimientos de los
alumnos sino que me permite enfocarme y
trabajar con grupos pequeños
además del hecho de que los alumnos
pueden trabajar a su propio ritmo la
conducta en el salón ha mejorado
notablemente ahora puedo enfocar mi
energía en enseñar en lugar de corregir
conducta
quita muchas distracciones la clase es
más tranquila los alumnos se emocionan
con los ejercicios y sus logros y como
es de esperarse disfrutan un poco de
competencia saludable estás mal no es
cierto
ya lo entendí bien una estrella
sabes que cállate siendo el mejor
me siento solo allá arriba
y la puntuación lo dice todo y ni
siquiera está actualizada
no digo que khan academy haya resuelto
todos los problemas de la educación
urbana ni mucho menos que los profesores
sean obsoletos pero la verdad es que con
algunas computadoras baratas y este
increíble programa gratuito mi salón de
clases se transformó radicalmente y los
alumnos han aprendido más gracias khan
academy
veis a domicilio
sí
no
ver más bien qué son
e
así
y